let me i think the funniest story and
the hardest that we've ever laughed on
this podcast was with dave england
telling
the story about putting poop on your
door your hotel door
all because you peed on his teddy bear
no i pee the piss was after
i came home and there was like i [__]
grabbed the door
it was france i think paris paris
getting ready to go to amsterdam yeah
and uh we're shooting we're like yeah
shooting jackass the tv show yep and uh
i go to my room and [__] grab the
handle and like you got [__] i got [__]
on my hand
and so now i've gotta [__] figure out
who did it it didn't take long to figure
it out like because you were with gooch
uh no i went and found gooch right away
and like yeah because gucci was good was
actually staying with dave but de gooch
didn't sell them out like it's like
right i just figured it out quickly and
gooch let me in the room i had access so
uh and i i tried this [__] in his
luggage so bad
i said i'm a gucci
ass gooch like i sat over his [__]
luggage
right there in the room
and i squatted and just tried to force
one out and i couldn't so
i just peed all over
everything he had yeah he was
particularly upset because he had bought
a stuffed animal for his
to [__] him
but that okay by the way i took this
[__] out and then put it back in so he
wouldn't notice so like oh okay he would
have been safe giving that to his kid if
he sinks down it doesn't go up right i
mean i mean yeah dude
but then he went home like he got so
chapped he was like it wasn't just that
he went home he called the area and he
cancelled all our flights and he called
the airlines canceled all your flights
cancelled all your hotels i think he was
able to do that like how like
how on top of it are you
to be able to do like i never would
think to do that even if i was so mad
i couldn't i couldn't do it i would need
help doing that even if i came up with
the idea it's so funny man when i was a
little kid and i called every hotel in
the yellow pages to meet motley crew and
i got my photo taken with nikki six and
tommy lee and then after that because
that was i was 13. for the rest of my
life my dad always said
if you could just apply yourself because
if you could just apply the the tenacity
if you could show the motivation that
you showed to meet motley crew then you
could do anything and like here with
dave if you could
right like
incredible you'd be the king of the
world
tenacity and there's the
absolute motivated assholeness right to
do that it's incredible
right yeah like yeah and and where's his
motivation like think about that like
like
how
devolved we got after that like so
peeing in luggage back then was the
biggest
like the biggest violation you could do
to somebody like fast forward just
a year and a half and
we all know what each other's piss
tastes like
you know what i mean we all know like
it's gotten so bad like
like that's just where we were at the tv
show then right yeah dude
thanks for watching that clip and if you
live in america there's a good chance
that this big badass tour bus is coming
to your town with my bucket list tour
what is it well it's an x-rated show
full of all the stuff that i would have
never have been allowed to do for
jackass and a lot of it is flagrantly
illegal so it's adults only and if you
live in any of these states then you
better go to stevo.com and check out my
tour schedule hurry up and get your
tickets too because it's selling out
everywhere
yeah dude
[Music]